right now I turn the phone line a man
who spent 15 years in the National
Football League Heisman Trophy winner
from USC and a good friend of the
program number one overall pick back in
his day he is carson palmer how are you
Carson you got it a man who knows his
facial hair and you do you want to chime
in on our poll question today to start
everything off the best of mustache in
television or if you heard the choices
that we have out there
Carson boys I mean I I I actually used
to rock a Detroit Tiger hat back in the
day and did couldn't name a player on
the team but magnum p.i used to rock
that hat so I did myself pretty serious
I think he's an obvious pick for runaway
and in fact hmm he had the mustache in
which every mustache was judged
thereafter well I mean I do have to on
behalf of Burt Reynolds step in here and
and say but maybe just television was
and we're looking at right now at the
Detroit Tiger hat so you would watch
magnum p.i and young Carson Palmer
growing up said I got a I got a rock the
Detroit Tiger hat because of Magnum I
love the show like I said for a long
time I couldn't have told you a player
on the team but magnum p.i was wearing
the hat so so was that is that why you
have a Ferrari now - Carson you slide
across the hood of it when you get home
that's what you do alright let's let's
get into some football conversation your
name came up last couple weeks going at
Trent Dilfer on talking about Tom Brady
and how he will look in the Bruce Arians
offense or how the two of them will work
together and he's like you know who
would talk very well on this front about
it would be carson palmer so now here
you are how do you feel the aryans brady
marriage will go carson well i think
it's gonna be great
I mean Bruce's you know he's a very
difficult guy to play for he's he has
very very high expectations he doesn't
put up with a lot of nonsense
but he treats his vets like like adults
and like vets and he treats the young
guys like young guys and obviously Brady
come in there and having the experience
he has I I see him running and then
running a lot of what Bruce's offense
has been for a number of years but I
also see Tom coming in and going look I
need my dirty pass plays but I
absolutely love we can we can you know
return them and put them in your
language so they fit in the Bruce Arians
offense but I would I would almost be
positive and I don't know this for a
fact but Tom's coming in and really
running the bread and butter of what
he's been running for the past 20 years
I mean there are very few quarterbacks
that get to play really in the same
system their entire careers and for 20
years in New England that was you know
it was you know first it was Charlie
Weis and Bill O'Brien and then Josh
McDaniels but really that was that was
Brady's offense if you go back and look
at the years they're running the same
concept year after year after year you
know it goes from you know Wes Welker
into Julian Edelman and then just
continues to evolve into different
players but really it's the bread
butters of what he's been running for
the last 20 years so I would I would
assume that Tom's going in New England
with his top 30 40 pass plays and really
kind of building what Bruce is often
doesn't have or isn't you know doesn't
have similar place to what Brady's been
running for so long and then building
upon that so I think at the end of the
day it's a really good mixture of those
two guys offenses Carson you started
your answer with two statements that
normally would be contradictory you said
it's gonna go great and then you said
earrings is difficult to play for
normally that sounds like that would be
a bad mix what makes him so difficult to
play for that actually is great for a
quarterback Carson doesn't it I mean
really really great to play for but
really really difficult and very
demanding and very high expectations you
know it'd be one thing to be a
first-year quarterback and a rookie
quarterback under Bruce so it would be a
long long season but being Tom and
and having his accomplishments and you
know his 20-plus years of experience I
think Bruce is going to treat him really
really well and treat him like a vet but
I think tom is used to a certain
standard and Bruce demand that same kind
of standard that that I think Belichick
does in New England so I think that mesh
is going to be really well it's not
going to be that far off as far as how
difficult practice is going to be how
intense meetings are going to be how you
really have to be on top of your game
whether you're sitting in the classroom
and Bruce is up in front of the group or
you're out there on the practice field
or you're you know on the sidelines in
game that he is always on it he's very
strict you can I if you're a young
receiver and you line up in the wrong
spot you know more than one time you're
probably it's probably be a couple days
to you get another rep on the practice
field he does not put up with nonsense
and not knowing your stuff and that's a
lot of what we hear out of Tom's or out
of Bill Belichick in New England is he's
difficult to play for he's very
demanding so you know I I don't think
it's too big of a transition for Brady
he's not going to you know a very loosey
goose environment with a lot of you know
pump up speeches and and you know some
of the stuff you hear at other different
teams in the league he's going to kind
of a similar guy expects you to be on
your P's and Q's he expects you to have
already watched your opponent coming in
to the next week and know who you know
know the defenses you're playing and you
know know the personnel I mean he is he
is not easy to play for but as long as
you take care of your business
you play to his standard and the
standard you set for yourself and you
you come into a game week knowing you
know your opponent and knowing what
blitz has come up on third down and what
to expect in the red zone as long as you
stay on top of your game Bruce is great
to play for so what's the most difficult
this begs the question begs the follow
up Carson Palmer what's the most
difficult memory or the most difficult
Ariane's was to you that leaps out from
your memory give me the most difficult
moment Bruce let you get away with
anything his you know his point is this
is the National Football League guys
aren't running around wide open you have
to create you have to
guys open and throw guys open and use
your eyes to open up you know receivers
and tight ends and running backs out of
the backfield but he's just always on
and and he's great he's great to have a
beer with and play golf with but when
you're at the facility you better be on
your game and you better know if he asks
you a question you better know the
answer or else he's you're gonna hear
about it and you're gonna hear about it
and so is everybody else on that team
because he's going to say it loud enough
that everybody hears him you know making
sure you know your stuff and and from
everything we all know about Tom is if
she shows up ready to work he shows up
prepared so I just think that mesh is
gonna be really really natural and easy
for the two of them Carson Palmer here
on the Rich Eisen show so you say again
Tom will come in with a bunch of plays
and Bruce will change the language Byron
Leftwich will place it all into an
offense and off they go
what do you say to people who think it's
not maybe a scheme fit because of the no
risk it no biscuit Tom's gonna be 43
there might not be enough people back to
protect etc so on and so forth that's
definitely been part of the conversation
I've heard a lot about yeah I mean you
look at Bruce's offense and he sits and
I kind of you know he empties the
backfield and they're in spread offense
no backs in the backfield no extra tight
end and blocking it's five on five you
know five offensive linemen blocking
four or five pass rushers so I mean that
that's what that's what Bruce wants to
be in he wants to give you as many
options as you can have with with having
five guys out in a route and you look
back especially back in the day in the
mid-2000s you know Brady was in a ton of
empty packages and we just would sit at
the line of scrimmage and no huddle
tight scenarios and redirect protections
and pick up a lot of different blitzing
schemes that people were bringing out
them and throw the ball down the field
so I think those two guys see the game
the same now can Ken Brady still on a
seven-step no hitch type of pass place
throw at 65 yards if he's got the right
coverage and the right pattern on
probably not he's probably a guy that
needs to get the top of his drop be
moving up in the pocket and be able to
really hitch into throws to get the ball
down the field
that is going to take away some of the
stuff that Bruce loves to do but what
you lose with Brady you know in in his
arm being 42 years old and maybe not
having you know the same carry on his
long balls maybe not having the same arm
strength you gain so many other things
when you his ability of the line of
scrimmage to dissect what you're
bringing defensively and put himself and
the guys around them in the correct
protection for that blitz he is second
to none so what you lose physically with
Brady's age and all the all the wear and
tear in his body you gain so much from
there and then you throw in the whole
leadership aspect and the expectation
aspect every day those guys are having
to walk in the facility with maybe the
greatest quarterback to ever play the
game
I mean you gain so much when when you
weigh the the gains versus the losses
and the pluses versus the - that's with
Brady and his age it just has so much
more to offer with his leadership and
his ability to to run an offense at the
line of scrimmage before I let you go
Carson Palmer the the big story outside
of the Super Bowl at the Super Bowl was
where Brady was going to go now we know
the answer to that the other story
outside of the Super Bowl was so big
involved Joe burrow and whether he
wanted to be drafted by Cincinnati your
brother being his throwing guru and your
comments about the Bengals you realize
you kind of threw everything into the
frying pan right Carson I'm going to
give an answer and you know outside of
you know outside of the Bengals
organization I don't think there's many
people that would argue that they
haven't been really very competitive for
the last 20 years
[Music]
so that's basically what I was saying
right and but it's different now right I
mean I know the owners the same but they
seem to have a
would you say it would you say that
still stands your statement I don't know
I I haven't been there in six or seven
years so I can't speak to how things are
currently operating right I just hope
that they are taking those those strides
and making an effort you know to to get
up to speed with the rest of the league
and be on par with the rest of the
league as far as you know everything
that goes into building organization and
building your culture and and just over
the last I don't know how many years or
decades they just haven't consistently
shown an effort to try to win a Super
Bowl and do whatever it takes and hire
you know a GM that can come in and and
you know move things in the right
direction they seem to just kind of be
sitting in the same spot they have been
for for the last handful of decades and
I know from you know just friends in the
area and and lifelong Bengal fans I know
it's frustrating from their perspective
it's frustrating from a you know a
player's perspective when you come from
one organization and then get there and
see how things were done it can be
frustrating so I think there's just a
lot of pent up frustration from you know
past players maybe some current players
but I know definitely from the fan base
and Joe's and exciting players he's an
exciting talent I mean he's an Ohio kid
I know you know that team and that
organization means a lot to him growing
up in that area it's opportunity to play
in front of his family and play in front
of his high school teammates you know
all the people that are still there that
he grew up around and and that he means
so much to so you know if what it looks
like it looks like he's going to go
there if he goes there you know he's got
his work cut out for him that's a really
difficult division division to be in you
got to play against Baltimore you're in
you're out you got to play against
Pittsburgh year and you're out
Cleveland's kind of a wild-card because
they have this massive amount of talent
on their roster so it's an uphill battle
no doubt and the teams that pick number
one you always have enough to uphill
battle because you had the worst record
in the league the previous year so you
know I'm excited for him I think it's
kind of every kid's dream to go and play
for their hometown team and get to play
in your home
State or your home city so that is
that's unique and not special not many
people get that opportunity and it looks
like chosen to get that chance Carson
you're the man really appreciate you
coming on the show best your family best
your wife best your kids best to all the
palmer's you take care of yourself
thanks for the time thank you
right back at you go that's Carson
Palmer right here on the Rich Eisen show